[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قالت مصادر امنيه في سيناء ان
ضابطا بالقوات المسلحه قتل وجرح ثلاثه
مجندين اخرين في تفجير استهدف اليه عسكريه
جنوب مدينه العريش كما اصيب اكثر من 40
شرطيا في هجوم على معسكر لقوات الامن في
العريش وقتل مدني واحد وتاتي هذه الهجمات
قبيل ايام من عقد المؤتمر الاقتصادي في
شرم الشيخ نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه
في محورين ما هي اسباب تدهور الوضع الامني
في سيناء وفي محافظات مصريه
اخرى وهل هناك مجال للحوار والحل السياسي
من اجل لاستقرار الوضع في
مصر تتصعد اضا الهجمات المسلحه التي
تستهدف ضباط وافراد الجيش والامن المصريين
في سيناء وفي محافظات اخرى وذلك رغم تشديد
القبضه الامنيه حتى بعد هذه الهجمات حتى
باتت هذه الهجمات روتينا يوميا وياتي
التدهور الامني في مصر قبل ايام من عقد
مؤتمر اقتصادي في شرم الشيخ بهدف جذب و
تشجيع الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبعيد تعيين
وزير داخليه جديد خلفا لمحمد ابراهيم الذي
اقاله الرئيس السيسي التفاصيل في التقرير
التالي لم يتوقف سقوط القتلى والجرحى من
المدنيين ورجال الشرطه والجيش المصريين
رغم كل ما تعلنه الدوله من تقدم على ساحه
مكافحه العنف المسلح في سيناء احدث تجليات
مسلسل العنف المتواصل انفجار انتحاري
استهدف صباح الثلاثاء معسكر قوات الامن
المركزي بالعريش واوقع اكثر من 40 جريحا
من قوات الامن بالاضافه لمقتل مدني واحد
تباهت وزاره الداخليه بسرعه التعامل مع
الشاحنه المفخخه قبل اقتحامها المعسكر ما
قلل عدد الضحايا لكن هذا لا يلغي حقيقه
تصاعد وتيره العنف حادث لم يكن الاول ولا
يبدو انه سيكون الاخير هذا ما يصر على
تكراره في كل مناسبه رئيس البلاد المسؤول
عن حفظ دماء شعبها كل اللي انتم شايفينه
ده احنا كنا عارفينه اقول تاني كنا
عارفينه لان احنا عارفينهم اقول كمان مره
تكرار لا يمنع سيل الاسئله المطروحه عن
جدوى السياسه الامنيه الراهنه في سيناء
سواء ما وقع من تهجير لسكان الشريط
الحدودي او ما يتواصل من قصف للمنشات
المدنيه في مناطق مختلفه وهو ما تصر
السلطات منذ سنوات على بقائه بعيدا عن
اعين العالم هذه الصور الحصريه التي حصلت
عليها الجزيره تساعد على قراءه مختلفه لما
وراء دوامه العنف المتسعه قذائف الجيش
المصري تستهدف قبل ايام معهدا ازهريا
بقريه المقاطعه جنوبيه الشيخ زويد بحثا عن
ارهابيين مفترضين طمرت الانقاض احلام جيل
يرى السكان المحليون هنا انه يفقد ابائه
ومستقبله برصاص جيش البلاد هنربي ادنا و
خليهم يسروا لابائهم وانتم حسابكم عند
الله عز وجل تضيق مساحه الامل كثيرا بعد
سماع هذه الكلمات حتى مع تعيين وزير
داخليه جديد كان يفترض ان يقدم طرحا
مختلفا عن سابقه وهو ما شكك فيه كثيرون
راوا في الرجل تكرارا لتجربه حبيب العدل
في عهد مبارك بحكم سابقه العمل الطويل في
مباحث امن
الدوله على ان العنف لم يعد وقفا على
سيناء فاستهدف العربات والمنشات ونقاط
تفتيش الامنيه للشرطه والجيش صار في حكم
الروتين اليومي في محافظات الداخل المصري
لا تنشغل الدوائر الرسميه في مصر بايجاد
مخارج سياسيه من الوضع الامني الراهن بقدر
ما تنشغل بالحشد للمؤتمر الاقتصادي
المرتقب الذي يتساءل كثير من المراقبين عن
صلاحيه البيئه الامنيه المحتقنه حاليا
لاقامته وتحديدا في شرم الشيخ جنوبي
سيناء انضم الينا في حلقه اليوم من سويسرا
دكتور حاتم عزام نائب رئيس حزب الوسط وعضو
مجلس الشعب المصري السابق ومن واشنطن
دكتور نبيل ميخائيل استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه جورج واشنطن دكتور نبيل ميخائيل
ما سبب تدهور الوضع الامني في مصر برايك
حاليا هو تدهور بيحدث في مناطق معينه يعني
مدينه القاهره المحافظه مدينه تعداد
سكانها اكثر من 10 مليون لكن الحوادث
الارهابيه قلي ان لم تكن نادره هناك ثغرات
يعني هستخدم التعبير الانجليزي لوب هولز
في ثغرات معينه في عده مناطق في مصر اما
فيها جماعات متطرفه او التغطيه او الحمايه
الامنيه ليها قليله فبالتالي بيبقى في نوع
من الهجوم المباغت المفاجئ على تجمعات
سكانيه بحيث انها رسالتها تكون اقوى من
الحدث نفسه لكن وزاره الداخليه قويه وحتى
تغيير قيادتها معناه ان هناك مراجعه لاداء
المسؤولين هناك ثغرات امنيه تستخ جماعات
متطرفه لكن استطيع القول بان الوضع الامني
في مصر يعني يعني مستقر وفي نوع من التحسن
دكتور حاتم عزام هل هنالك تحسن
برايك الحقيقه انا تحياتي لحضرتك ولضيفك
الكريم ول الجمهور ا انا لم اسمع الحقيقه
يعني انا لم اسمع خالص الدكتور نبيل
ميخائيل يقول في المحصله هنالك تحسن اسالك
هل ترى ترى الامر كذلك هل هنالك فعلا ثغر
امنيه ولكن هنالك
تحسن لا الحقيقه يعني انا شايف انه الوضع
في سيناء خصوصا وفي في مصر
عموما يتجه امنيا الاسوا ليس للافضل
ويعني اعتقد انه كل الحلول العسكريه مش
فقط الامنيه الحلول العسكريه التي تتخذها
سلطه انقلاب الثالث من يوليو حتى الان لم
تزيد الامر الا تعقيدا لانه الارهاب الذي
كان محتملا صار حقيقيا وانه التعامل لو
بنتكلم عن سيناء ومصر كلها ف مصر المجال
العام فيها بقى مجال عسكري وليس مجال مدني
ف القوات المسلحه هي التي تتحدث في كل شيء
في كل الحلول السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه وبالاخص في سيناء اعتقد انه
التعامل مع الازمه في سيناء ومع المشكله
الجماعات المسلحه في سيناء التي نعرف انها
كانت موجوده وكانت توجه ضرباتها الى
اسرائيل كم تم التعامل وتوسيع مجال
التعامل العسكري مع كل اهل سيناء بلا ضابط
وبشكل موسع وبشكل عشوائي حتى طال المنازل
وطال المعاهد وطال المساجد وطال مزارع
الزيتون وطال كل شيء وانتهى بالتهجير
القصري لاهل شمال سيناء وانا اعتقد انه
هذا الحقيقه يؤدي الى خطر كبير لان كل
الجماعات التي كانت قليله ستزداد لان هذه
البيئه حضرتك عارفه انه سيناء فيها يعني
قبليه وفيها عائلات ممتده في كل مكان
ومساله الثق بالنسبه لهم مساله حيويه وجزء
كبير من اللي بقى يحصل النهارده هو بقت
عمليات ثاريه وانه السيسي نفسه حذر من هذا
يعني انا بحيل ضيف حضرتك انه السيسي نفسه
في في في تسجيل لو هو بيتكلم قاض القط
والجنود بتوعه بالصوت والصوره وانتم
بتجيبوه في البرومو بيقول احنا نقدر نفجر
بيوت سينا ونقدر نخلي شمال سينا وفي رفح
ونفجر بيوتها لكن ده احنا كده بنخلق عدو
وهو في نفس فعلا نفس الشيء انا عايز احيل
حضرتك والسيد نبيل ميخائيل الى صحيفه
الجور زليم بوست بتاريخ 4 او 9 اغسطس 2014
التي تحدثت على انه هناك سياسيين
اسرائيليين يثنون على خطه السيسي او
البروبوزال او العرض بتاع السيسي
ل
اعطاء الفلسطينيين ارض في شمال سيناء وفي
سيناء حتى تزداد مساحه غزه الى خمس اضعاف
مساحتها الحاليه وانه اسرائيل رحبت بهذا
العرض ولكن ممدوح محمود عباس هو الذي رفض
وبالتالي نحن في سيناء امامنا حاله خاصه
جدا اعتقد انه المقصود منها وال المستفيد
الرئيس الوحيد هو اسرائيل واعتقد انه عبد
الفتاح السيسي بيفعل هذا لمصلحه اسرائيل
لانه هو اذا كان هو بنفسه بيقول كده في
هذا التسريب ف وهو يعي هذا تماما فلماذا
يقدم على هذا وانه هذا التصريح بتاع الجزل
بوست انا ذكرته لحضرتك وذكرت تاريخه يمكن
لجميع الرجوع اليه دكتور نبيل مخائيل هل
لديك رد على ذلك هل يساهم السيسي في اراحه
اسرائيل من خلال هذه العمليات في
سيناء
ا السيسي كرئيس للجمهوريه بيعمل على مصلحه
مصر لانه رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه ممكن
تكون هناك دول مستفيده يعني لو مصر امنت
البوابه الشرقيه ليها وهي شبه جزيره سينا
ما هوو ايضا لخدمه الفلسطينيين ستكون
الحدود الفلسطينيه مستقره وسيساهم هذا في
اعلان فلسطين كدوله مستقله الامر يتوقف
على مدى فهم دول اخرى لافعال مصر لكن
السيسي لا يؤتم بالقياده الاسرائيليه
السيسي يعمل لمصلحه المصريين وليست لمصلحه
الاسرائيلين طيب اذا كان يعمل لمصلحه عن
صح اي مصلحه في هدم بيوت ناس في سيناء
وصفهم لنا السيد حاتم عزام وما يؤدي الى
مزيد من الاستعداء ومزيد من ثقافه الثار
في في
الجانبين
ا محافظه شمال سينا
بتشهد نوع من العنف حتى النهارده صحيفه
نويورك تايمز علقت على الهجمات الاخيره في
سيناء فقالت
اند لو فايولينس يعني عنف قليل او بطيء
شبه جزيره سينا كمحافظ ليست محافظه درعه
في سوريا نعم هناك مشاكل هناك نوع من
التوتر لكن المشهد ليس حرب اهليه يعني
طبعا من حق كل شخص الاقامه في اي مكان
يختاره لكن سمعنا مثلا وانا مش عاوز اعبر
عن اي لغه طائفيه ان هناك تهجير لا او
محاوله لتهجير المسيحيين الاباط من شمال
سينا ما حدش اعترض على كده اتمنى ان يبقى
الجميع في شمال سينا مسلمين ومسيحيين او
اي اتباع ديانه اخرى الموضوع ان سينا ما
زالت خاضعه للاداره للاراده المصريه
والاداره المصريه ف لكن هتكون ساحه قتال
وعنف الى فتره
طويله لو قرتها مثلا دكتور نبيل اي اي
تهجير اي تهجير هو مفترض ان يكون مستهجن
ومستنكر ولكن المساله ان سيناء الان تحت
قبضه امنيه مشدده معزوله لا ليس لا يسمح
للصحفيين بتصوير ما يجري هناك ورغم كل هذه
الاجراءات لا تزال الاعتداءات على الجيش
والشرطه قائمه ما يعني ان هنالك مشكله ما
الا تشعر
بذلك طبعا هناك مشكله امنيه ومشكله امنيه
خطيره لكن الامن عنده خبره يعني في السابق
مثلا في الثمانينات او حتى في السبعينيات
كانت محافظه اسيوط
تشكل يعني تحدي امني كبير للقيادات
المصريه وبعد اختيال الرئيس سدات حصل نوع
من التمرد هناك والشرطه والجيش ادخلوا في
عناصر بتقاوم الحكومه في سينا الحكومه
بتحاول فرض سيطرتها هناك يعني من الناحيه
البيروقراطيه مثلا هناك قياده عسكريه
جديده استحدثت ق وهي القياده الشرقيه
واعتقد ان براسها اللواء او الفريق اسامه
رشدي عسكر يعني هنا في مسؤوليه في تعامل
امني مع جماعات متطرفه هل سيتم الصلح
الامر بيعتمد اولا على سير القتال ورغبه
الطرفين في الوصول الى صلح لكن لا اعتقد
ان الحكومه ستطرح مبادره بالصلح مع تلك
الجماعات المتطرفه في سينا لانها ترجح
انها تستطيع التغ عليهم فالمشهد الامني
هيكون في توتر الى فتره طويله لكن اهم
حاجه هو استقرار مصر سيد حاتم عزام هل
يمكن اقامه صلح مع هكذا جماعات كما يطرح
دكتور
نبيل هو دعيني اعقب سريعا على حاجه قالها
الدكتور نبيل ميخائيل هو بيقول انه السيسي
رئيس مصر انا لا ارى ان سيس رئيس مصر انا
اراه وزير الدفاع اتى بانقلاب وهناك جزء
وقطاع الاوسع اكثر من يعني نصف المجتمع
المصري انا اداعي ان هو يرى هذا
الكلام نمره اثنين هو بيقول انه السيسي
بيعمل لصالح مصر يعني هذا رايه انما هذا
ليس الواقع الواقع يقول انه لا ان الاوضاع
في مصر الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاجتماعيه
والامنيه والعسكريه اسوا مما كانت عليه
قبل لاه سبعه نمره لاثه انا ذكرت تحديدا
تقرير نشر في الجورج لين بوست هو لم يتحدث
عنه ر على سؤال حضرتك انا بقول لا انه هو
حضرتك الاشكاليه الان انا برايي تحولت من
مواجهه مجموعات مسلحه تعمل كانت ضد توجه
ضرباتها ضد اسرائيل ا السيسي اتخذ القرار
بشن
حرب حتى يعني مفردات الدكتور نبيل بيتكلم
على سير القتال وسير القتال احنا اتحولنا
الى حرب في بلدنا يا استاذه غاده يعني
السيناويين مواطنين مصريين وانا اتفق مع
دكتور نبيل انه لا يمكن ان نهجر لا مسيحي
ولا مسلم لكن هو هو لم يتحدث انه السيسي
هجر الناس من منازلهم هو من الذي هجر
المنازل من الذي فجر المنازل حضرتك متخيله
انه اما نفجر منازل الناس ونهجر قصريه و
24 24 ساعه مهله ان هم يشوفوا مكان بديل
ولا يجدوا مكان بديل اما نفجر المدارس اما
نفجر المساجد اما نقتل بهذا الشكل القتل
العشوائي هل احنا كده ب واجه مجموعات
مسلحه محدوده ولا بنشن حرب على سيناء احنا
بنشن حرب على سيناء على شمال سيناء تحديدا
وانا بدعي انه هذا لا يخدم الا العدو
الاسرائيلي وانا
ذكرت قرينتي لهذا الادعاء تؤكده اول شيء
انه السيسي نفسه تحدث انه هذا خطر داهم
اذا حصل وان هو لا يمكن يعمل كده وان
الجيش اداه قتل ولا يمكن يدخل الجيش في
هذا المعترك ولا يمكن يفجر اهالي الناس في
سينا وبيتهم وفعل هذا ثم تحدث عن تقرير
الجور لين بوست في اغسطس فانا بكلم حضرتك
بالعقل والمنطق والحجه ما يحدث الان في
سيناء هو ق علىك اكبر بكثير جدا اكبر
بكثير
جدا انه يمكن ان ينظروا كما يشاؤون للسيسي
لكن هو بالنسبه اليه يراه رئيسا ويراه
يعمل لصالح مصر هذا ردا على ذكرت عن جروز
بوست على كل حال سوف اتوقف مع فاصل قصير
واعود بع لكما ضيفي ولكم مشاهدينا ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد دكتور نبيل
الملاحقات القضائيه قائمه القبضه الامنيه
قائمه ورغم ذلك الوضع الامني لا يزال
متدهورا هل من مجال للتفكير بحل اخر لمنع
التدهور الامني في سيناء وفي محافظات
مصريه اخرى عبر حل سياسي مثلا هل من
امل
ممكن كل الخيارات مطروحه الامر بيعتمد على
اذا كانت القياده السياسيه والعسكريه في
مصر تفضل حل عن الاخر لكن انا مستعد في
يعني في خلال البرنامج اطرح عده امور زي
مثلا ضروره تمثيل قوي لسينا في البرلمان
المصري الجديد يجب ان يكون هناك نواب
منتخبون من سينا بيتحدث عن مشاكلها
قضاياها
وغيرها الامر الاخر عدم يعني تحليل او
تفسير الموقف في سينا على انه جزء من
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي لان ده هيضر
الفلسطينيين وبعدين مش حيكون لمصلحه اهل
سينا هذا المجال التسريب كان واضحا وتقرير
جيرز بوست الذي اشار اليه حاتم عزام كان
واضحا لا يمكن تجاهل هذه الامور لا يمكن
تجاهل ان مصر تغلق مع برفح وتشدد الخناق
على اهل وسكان غزه الفلسطينيين العرب لا
يمكن تجاهل ان حركه مقاومه القضاء المصري
ماعد يعتبرها الان ارهابيه لا يمكن تجاهل
كل ذلك هذا يخدم اسرائيل سواء شئت ام
ابيت ا باختصار يعني بعد حرب غزه كان هناك
جدل كبير حول اسلوب مصر في التعامل مع
حماس
وغيره لكن انا شخصيا ارى ان القياده
المصريه بتفصل ما بين بتفصل ما بين حماس
وما بين الجماعات الجهاديه داخل سينا ده ش
الامر خاص بسينا شان
اخر يعني اصل ما هو يعني هيبقى في صله اه
طبعا هيكون في صله عمليات تهريب عمليات
حفر انفاق لكن يعني انا في رايي ان حماس
هي عاوزه تكون الطرف السياسي الرئيسي في
غزه فده الامر اللي بيشغل القياده المصريه
الموضوع هو في مصر مصر وسيناء انت تقول
انت تتحدث الان عن حماس بانها تريد ان
تكون طرف ف فلتكن ما تكون في غزه هذا هذا
شانها يعني وهذا شانها وشان الفلسطينيين
في غزه لاي يعني هذا موضوع اخر بين اهل
غزه وحماس ومن يحكمهم ومن لا يحكم انا
اتحدث الان عن مساله الامن في سيناء عندما
تحاصر غزه بهذا الشكل وعندما تعتبر ان
حماس التي حاربت الارهاب اول واحده على
الحدود مع رفح اذا كنت تذكر عندما تعتبرها
هي ارهابيه وتغلق ال خناق على سكان سيناء
وتهدم منازلهم ماذا
تتوقع انا في رايي ان مصر بالتعامل مع
السلطه الفلسطينيه بتتعامل ايضا مع شعب
غزه يعني مصر بتتعامل مع غزه لان في
عائلات مشتركه في روابط كثيره ما بين غزه
وما بين مصر فمصر لم تقطع صلاتها بشعب غزه
انا بس بقول كمعالج للموقف الامني في سينا
لا داعي القول ان الجيش المصري يحارب
لصالح اسرائيل لان ده مش صحيح وبعدين ده
ؤدي الى عداء من قبل المصريين تجاه
الفلسطينيين واحنا عايزين العلاقات ما بين
المصريين والفلسطينيين تكون طيبه المصريين
هيقولوا انتم بتطلعوا
ا كيف تكون طيبه وانت تشارك في حصارهم سيد
حاتم عزام هل من مجال للحوار برايك في ظل
هذا
الوضع طيب انا انا حابب ا زي ما حضرتك
ذكرتي انه يعني ما نتكلمش على فلسطين لانه
يعني الاستاذ نبيل قال بلاش نتكلم او
دكتور نبيل قال بلاش نتكلم عنها ثم تكلم
هو عنها انما انا ما قلته بشكل واضح انه
المستفيد الوحيد مما يحصل الان في سيناء
هو اسرائيل وان سيسي يعرف انه اللي بيعمله
الان دلوقتي هو يفجر حروب داخليه داخل
الوطن المصري وانا قلت على تقرير منشور
فكذبوا السلطات المصريه الامر الاخر انا
عايز اكده لحضرتك ان اهل سينا وانه في
منهم ناس اتصلوا بيا شخصيا اكدولي انه في
الاسابيع الماضيه كانت هناك طائرات بدون
طيار اسرائيليه بتقصف منازلهم فاذا كان
الدكتور نبيل مش عارف هذه المعلومات يعني
ارجو ان هو يراجعها يتوثق منها وحينما
تهاجم طائرات بدون تيار اهلنا في سينا
يبقى بهدف ايه ما معنى التنسيق الامني بين
مصر واسرائيل في قطاع
سينا انا شايف حضرتك انه في مصر لن ينقذ
ما يتم في مصر من عسكره
الدوله سوى الحلول السياسيه التي غابت منذ
انقلاب الثالث من
يولي اول ما في رب رب قائل الان او من بمن
يسمعك ان يقول انت تبرر للارهاب انت لا
تعترف بانصار بيت المقدس الذين بايعوا
البغدادي وداعش او تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
هذا كله اين تذهب به يعني هل يبقى افراد
الجيش
ابناء الامن او الشرطه او الجيش وهم
مصريون بالاخر عرضه لهؤلاء كيف تحاور من
يهاجمك غير بان تردعه عنك
اولا انا اطلاقا لم اكل ما حضرتك تقوليه
بل بالعكس انا دائما ما اقول انه الدم
المصري كله واحد وانه دم ابنائنا واخواننا
الجنود الذين يسقطون
والمدنيين دم واحد وانه الذي يضع كل هؤلاء
في هذه المهلكه هو عبد الفتاح السيسي ده
كلام واضح يا استاذه غاده يعني لا يقبل
تاويل وانا ما وصفته هو توصيف للواقع انا
بقول انه هناك في الجماعات مسلحه فعلا هو
اقال محمد ابراهيم هل برايك عبد الغفار
كان حلا مقبولا
بديلا الوزير الداخليه الجديد ام هو يعني
يساهم في مزيد من تدهور الوضع الامني
برايك لا انا شايف ان الموضوع اكبر من
محمد ابراهيم ومن عبد الغف اي واحد هيجي
انت حضرك بت لو بتساليني عن حلول للوضع في
مصر انا بقول لحضرتك كمان بالمناسبه انه
احد الحاجات الروافض الاشكاليه في السينا
انه اغلاق المجال العام السياسي المدني في
مصر في القاهره مش في سينا يعني حينما
احنا شفنا ثلاث ثلاث شباب مصريين انضموا
الى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في داعش منهم
احمد الدراوي ده ضابط شرطه وكان صديقي
بالمناسبه وكان مؤمن بالعمل السياسي وكان
مرشح لمجلس الشعب وكان ضابط شرطه سابق جعل
ضم بحكم معرف بشكل سريع ساعود اليك ما
الذي جعله ينضم ما الذي جعله
ينضم هو انا انا لم اعرف هو لماذا انضم
انا كنت اعرفه وقت الثوره لكن ماعرفوش وقت
هو هضم انضم ليه لكن انا اجد
مبررا ربما تكون حاله فرديه سيد ح انا اجد
مبررا هو ستكون حاله فرديه دكتور لبيل سع
اسلام كان في اسلام يا ك سيد دكتور نبيل
كيف ترى تاثير الوضع الامني على المؤتمر
الاقتصادي المرتقب في شرم الشيخ بشكل
سريع طبعا في منطق ما بين اثنين لان لا
يمكن لراس المال انه يحضر لبلد لو الموقف
غير الامني غير مستقر لكن شركه مثلا
بريتيش بتروليوم زي ما طلعتنا الصحف
الامريكيه هذا الاسبوع بتستمر 12 مليار
دولار للتنقيب على البترول في مصر ومصر
دوله مش معروفه بمصادرها البتروليه
الكبيره ففي استثمارات اجنبيه كمان وضعنا
كمغترب يعني احنا بنحاول بعد سنوات طويله
في الغربه اقامه صله مع الوطن الام
بالخبره بالمعرفه بالاستثمار بشتى الوسائل
سيد حاتم عزام بشكل سريع جدا هل من امل
الحوار وهل من امل لاي نتيجه المؤتمر
الاقتصادي نعم ام لا نعم خليني بس اقول
لحضرتك شركه شركه بريتش بتروليوم اللي
اشار اليها دكتور نبيل هذا الموضوع منذ
1992 ودي اكبر اتفاقيه فاسده في تاريخ
قطاع الغاز المصري وتهدر 32 مليار دولار
على الحكومه المصريه وليس شيء جديد الامر
الامر الاخير انا شايف انه ما هو مطلوب في
مصر الان هو عوده الحياه المدنيه
الديمقراطيه مره اخرى ان يعود الجيش خطوه
للخلف حتى يمارس مهمته الرئيسيه ان يحاكم
كل من قتل المصريين وعلى راسهم عبد الفتاح
السيسي ومحمد ابراهيم وكل قاده الانقلاب
شكرا جزيلا من سويسرا حاتم عظام نائب رئيس
حزب الوسط وعضو مجلس الشعب المصري السابق
ومن واشنطن اشكرك دكتور نبيل ميخائيل
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه جورج
واشنطن الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء